algorithms okay thank you dick so two
two announcements first of all the paper
was also with changhua tank and dam
Spillman so that was the full list of
outers and I will not say what about
deep learning today don't be worried
unless you want me to okay so first of
all yes since this is like the final
lecture in this final open election
semester I'm probably the final lecture
of this semester I just want to say that
you know this was an amazing amazing
semester I think really really like you
know we don't when we were putting
together this proposal for this program
you know somehow we'd have an idea that
there is something interesting happening
and it will be nice to make it work but
you know only once we started inviting
people in such like we just created a
wish list of all the people we would
like to invite and almost all of them
said yes we knew that okay there is
something really special about to happen
and I can just say that indeed this was
true so honestly I must admit that in
the organizer once we arrived here I
didn't have to do much at this point
everything was in autopilot like it's
just the you know this like the
collection of the people that we invited
they just were carrying this program
forward so you know this was great and
thanks to the Simons Institute for both
hosting us and also having this kind of
reverence and kind of foresight to
actually economy apply the usual value
apply only for like one of the two
semesters semester slots and you know
when we and that's what we apply for but
essentially at that point Allister
probably after consulting with the rest
of the same host ball so that actually
how about you just do the first like
jumbo program where you actually will
take both semesters because it is
clearly things happening and there is
more people to bring in and you know and
that was a very good that was a very
good decision I hope that that's what
they think now I definitely think so so
now this is the final lecture so this
might be a good occasion for trying to
reminiscent about what we achieved so
far but probably this will be a bit too
early I think you know the right time
for this will be in a year or so for now
I know there are some interesting things
happening but they're a bit too early to
talk about it so instead what I'd help
to do I try to use this publicity to
somehow sort of like you know promote a
certain view of algorithms or
rather the view I would like to have of
all of the algorithms that I believe is
very much in line in what this semester
is about and I hope that I will
convinced you that this is actually
something you know interesting and
possible and something that maybe you
would be interested in taking on as well
okay so let me just start without
further ado so the point of start is
just know this very simple statement I
think no one can really content that
algorithm is a great success story so
the fields of algorithm is a great
success story so last 50 years
I really would argue this was like the
golden era of algorithms okay so
essentially we had a lot of like we like
I think every five years at least we
have some like fundamentally new idea
that we bring to the field and this
ideas go then on like beyond you know
stop fox publications there are actually
influence CS you know CS at large and
somehow become now the backbone of CS so
this is all great any particular by now
you know if you look at these books or
you look at the literature in the field
you will discover a true wealth of
techniques you know that people can
apply it and develop it can apply to
various problems and so far you have it
it's like a very versatile tool kit that
essentially for you know whatever you
want to solve the Travis is someone who
already developed some interesting
clever approach to that so that's all
great should feel very good about that
but you know there is something that you
know I think it's a little bit music so
just to highlight that let me just sort
of give you my kind of very simplified
and very very kind of subjective view of
the field ok so you can view algorithms
as a kind of tool and then talking about
TCS algorithm by the way as you know as
the you know two trends of algorithms so
first one is this kind of combinatorial
algorithms and this would be the classic
algorithms as you know from CRS or any
of the you know undergrad address
classes so these are all this like
classic you know classic graph
algorithms like Dijkstra or you know max
flow algorithms or you know data
structures and all the fun that we like
to be tortured during the
Google interviews questions okay so this
is the like classic core of algorithms
but then if over years there was a kind
of this different kind of algorithms is
like a bit of a weird kind of algorithm
a mystic the algorithms where you use
things like random walks in linear
algebra to do some cool stuff okay so
essentially I must have made that you
know I'm not that old but I'm old enough
to remember where spectral algorithms
was something that you know sort of
people did but not did not talk too much
about you know it was kind of niche I'll
go to work
you know it gave some very nice results
for very specific context but it was not
something that was viewed as a like you
know a major part of Education of a
girl's education of every researcher
okay so in particular I remember when I
was starting my studies at PG sites at
MIT you know this kind of reading things
about random spanning trees or about
like no Spillman tank lapis and silver
was a bit of a guilty pleasure for me
essentially this was a school math but I
couldn't really comprehend you know why
would you care about doing it's like if
you want to do algorithms of course then
I started reading this papers in more
detail and then suddenly things became
more and more clear and you know that's
essentially changed the way this you
know not essentially like you know in
time I understood why this is like a
very valuable contribution in particular
in 2014 we had this semester program at
Simon's Institute about spectral graph
theory
which I think did a lot to solidify this
kind of knowledge particularly realize
that spectra albertans just like a
sliver of what we are really trying to
do here and what you really wanted to do
and didn't know that was to continue
optimization and somehow once we
understood that well that was the
trigger for this semester where is it
okay now we know what we should learn
and now we know the other communities
you should connect to and maybe this is
time to you know bring in these guys
talk to them and figure out you know
what are the commonalities between us
what can we learn from each other okay
and that's exactly the genesis of this
program and that's what we were hoping
to achieve
and he'll quite quickly
even before the program happened it was
already became clear that this kind of
combination of conducive to mediation
and committed techniques and data
structures actually is a very powerful
mix it gives us you know it gives us a
lot of a lot of power in particularly
the neighbor of significant progress on
Saturn
long-standing questions in algorithms
okay and you know both in the continues
and the end the commuter legwork but
somehow what I want to focus about I
will talk about some of these
developments but somehow they focus I
want to have is not on what we achieved
but also a certain different impact that
I hope this already had and will have on
algorithms so sort of what I wants to
argue is that you know one thing why I
really so like this continued
optimization view on algorithms but it's
not only because it gives us powerful
tools but also because it gives us a
very certain unified and principled way
of thinking about algorithmic problems
okay so somehow the meta Al Gore's but
they always have in mind and it's sort
of like if you don't even realize that
sometimes you know each problem seems to
require like restarting from a beginning
you have to be smart but in the end you
know you have to start from scratch if
you want to solve a new program it's a
problem so what I like about compute
optimization that actually it's
completely brain-dead like essentially
it's clear what has to happen okay that
was not an instant that was actually a
praise I view it as a like I think the
highest kind of Albert's will be when
everything will be automatic and you
will not have to essentially will be out
of jobs that will be the perfect world
for algorithms for me and so that's why
I'm doing deep learning so I can I can
change my okay so what would be the
underlying meta algorithm so essentially
like what you do is again very simple
you have your problem just formulated as
a continues eating tasks like cassaday's
linear program unconstrained a you know
mediation problem whatever you like
there is like a lot of flexibility to do
a lot now you have that condition
temptation task what do you do well
there's plenty of off-the-shelf
algorithms to solve it just apply it
well you already have an outward and you
know we didn't have to think much about
it already
of course you know usually this of the
chef a guru will not be perfect it will
mean the best a girl you can but still
you know there are principled ways of
tweaking it once you understand what you
are dealing with and adding some problem
specific insights but in the end this is
really an errata algorithm that works
surprisingly well in particular what
often happens if you look at the of the
application of the of this algorithm you
will discover that this corresponds to
some like very hard
earned Anoka Mitra are good for a
problem so it's really seems to be that
do you ever get a lot of shortcuts here
okay and actually this goes even more in
more so because honestly you think of
co2 elimination this is a field of one
algorithm it's a very nice field it's a
field of one algorithm and the algorithm
that I claim is the only algorithm you
have to really know is grain descent
method okay so you know so this is a one
out room to let them out and please do
not confuse it with another very
powerful algorithm that I like to likely
like to use many graduate student
descent it was great as well but you
know somehow you know it just not all of
us are lucky enough to be able to apply
it efficiently so sounds insane yes like
one algorithm for all the problems and
let's not fool ourselves it is insane
but it's much less at the point I want
to make in this talk is that this is
much less insane than you would actually
think okay so somehow what I will do
today is I will just show you how this
how this program or this view works out
for a couple of problems so actually I
will spend almost all the time on like I
what I see that is the like largest
success story so far for this approach
namely the maximum flow problem but also
I will touch very briefly on two other
problems and namely matrix scaling and
balancing and case error problem just to
show you that this is really not about
graph algorithms this is a much broader
phenomena and somehow here so they will
try to like find iridescent as a
unifying if you all three of these
problems and somehow the broader message
I want to send here is that you know for
the TCS folks I want to say you should
really not ignore convince atomization
actually I would claim you cannot ignore
it because that might be the future and
you might be by not thinking about which
atomization not trying to learn it you
want to miss out on very important
insights interact ly things that you'd
care about and also I want to make you
tea I want to make a case actually not
as scary as you can think so I will
essentially give you most of the
conceptual underpinnings
already in this talk all three now what
is what is the message I want to send to
the continued transition folks I want to
tell you is that you should view TCS has
a great you know rich and stimulating
domain where you can actually try to see
your tools in action in particular this
is domain that can inspire you to also
improve your
improve your tools okay and this already
has happened and I expected to this to
happen more and more as you understand
this two fields together better okay so
this is the message and now let's see
how I will do at delivering it so let's
just start by telling you about the main
character in the story in immigrants and
metal so I just give you a like a very
quick and dirty but actually essentially
the essential primer to this Matata
so what occurred in the sent so
Granderson is an algo designed to only
one problem namely unconstraint
minimization so what is unconstrained
minimization well essentially you just
have a function that is nice in a sense
it's continuous and smooth and all you
want to do is just we want to find a
minimum of this function over the domain
that's all you want to do very simple
but also very powerful because this is
very flexible now you know basic idea is
how would you solve this problem
in the simplest way possible you just
apply a continuous greedy improvement so
what does it mean well essentially what
he will do is all that you have to
figure out is this core primitive that
given some initial solution X just finds
a way to improve it a bit and then you
can just iterate this primitive over and
over and over and you will get an alert
okay so all that we need to understand
is just this primitive that takes you
know given a input X tries to find a new
point close to that point to that
initial point that is a bit better from
the point of view of minimizing the
function f so how do we go about this
again the approach is very simple all
you just have to do is just use Taylor
expansion of your function around your
point so that if you remember from the
old times of being subjected to you know
doing an algebra and analysis that's
exactly what you will be getting there
and you know what you realize about this
Taylor externships we don't really have
to understand what it is except two
important insights so essentially the
way to view this error proximation
serves as a as a new kind of combination
of two terms
so one of them is just this linear term
that just corresponds to likely local
approximation of F okay so this is just
the first two terms this is a constant
and this is just a linear term now the
second term is just everything else and
you can view it as kind of local
approximation error essentially how bad
your approximating of your function is a
linear function actually is how much you
are missing okay and we will always want
to
of this approximation as a quadratic
function okay specifically we'll assume
something that is actually very useful
property namely be the smoothness we
just assumed that this kind of tail is
over upper bounded by you know by better
over 2 times the quadratic in to this
basement okay that's a node that's the
way to view it and the moment you view
it you already know what the algorithm P
so what should you do so there's this
like key principle caught in stimulation
which says no matter how nasty our
algorithm is if you zoom in close enough
it will become very simple it will
become close to linear and that's all
that we are really doing here so what do
we do well we want to minimize that you
want to think of our function as a
linear function so what do you do to
minimize this linear approximation well
essentially you just have to move in the
direction of minus gradient so this is
exactly the local steepest decrease
direction so this is the greedy part of
the algorithm okay so this is no you
just wants to move if you ask yourself
where should I move to reduce this value
its function the most that's the
direction to move now how far do you
want to go well you need to like sort of
the thing that you need to do you need
to balance out the error of your inner
proximation so the further you move the
more error you'll accumulate so clearly
you want to balance the progress you
make with the error that you're actually
making and when you do this is very
simple math you will just get that the
right step set is 1 over bit okay so
this is a step size so now we know what
can we say about this well clearly we
now have a you know an algorithm does
the one thing about this algorithm is
that essentially wants the gradient
vanishes then you know we are converging
to a point this is like a critical point
of the function question is you know
what this point is is actually what
might happen in general is that this
function to this point is neither a
global or even local minimum of the
function so that's a problem in general
and again in deep learning that's a big
problem but you know what do you do in
everywhere else then deeper link imma
build everywhere else but in many many
consecrate Russia is surprisingly many
concept what you can do you can actually
assume that your functions also convex
and what it means in our language is
that this error in up in in the linear
approximation is actually always a
negative so we can only understood but
we never overshoot the value of this
function
it turns out that once you have this
everything is great essentially all the
you know critical points become global
Mema and essentially we have a working
algorithm okay so far so good and now
the question is okay so we know that
eventually we'll convert that question
is not how much how many steps we will
need to convert there and what you can
prove with not much work is essentially
if you want to be with an epsilon of the
optimum value all you just have to do we
just have to essentially take this
penetration so like there is like beta
times R squared over 1 over Epsilon when
R square R when are essentially the
distance of your initial point to the
optimum point that you are trying to
reach ok so this is you know this is
great and actually it turns out that you
can make things even better namely if
actually you have a stronger condition
that just simple convexity something
called stronger for convexity so you can
also lower bound your arrow like some
quadratic ok then things become even
better and the convergence you are
getting is actually you know B over
alpha times log R 1 over Epsilon so
essentially the important thing here is
that you know this is a logarithm so
this depends logarithmically on the
parameters of the problem so essentially
you can just you know this is just as
fast as you would ever want it to be and
the only thing you have to worry is
about this ratio of beta 2 alpha
essentially how how well do you sandwich
you know your error between this lower
bounding and a pargana quadratic so this
is usually called as condition number so
essentially your as long as your
position number is great it's good you
are you are converging very very fast
this is a joint like you can think of it
this then it's in exact Albert for a
problem okay so this is all I want to
tell you about greens in for now so
let's just try to see it in action and
as I said the main domain you will I
apply it to is the maximum flow problem
so does a quick reminder well the
maximum flow problem is so in this
problem we think of a graph G we've has
some capacity on edges and source s
NSYNC T and essentially what all that
you really want to do is we just want to
find a feasible feasible s the flow of
maximum value okay so we just want to
find a way of sending you know of
sending stuff from s to T so as you know
we don't have any leaks
and then you know we never film more
than the capacitor no the edges and then
you just say we just want to push as
much as possible as we can so in
particular when the capacitor or one
what you are trying to compute is just
the no maximum number of arc disjoint
and step off in the graph okay this is
the problem and I'm sure this is not the
first time you heard about this and you
know why do we care about this problem
it's definitely one of the most
fundamental graph problems and you know
the reason is that actually it captures
a lot of other optimization problems so
a lot of other optimization problems can
be reduced to it and over the last 50
years this was a problem that was like
extremely intensely studied okay that's
what one of the problems that we really
wanted to understand its complexity okay
so what have we found so far so this
would be like a very abbreviated history
of the problem so in the context of
sparse graphs which is sort of the best
regime for all this combinatorial
approaches to max flow the picture is
very simple as this to me so this is
like classic error where we use this
kind of purely committal algorithms and
essentially you know the you know the
the result of the result of all the
improvement that we got is that in the
end we have this emerging barrier of n
to the three halves that we just you
know met already for incapacity case in
the 70s but could not improve since then
okay so so that's the you know that's
the glory and also end of classical era
and then what happened recently is
actually that we somehow did things a
bit differently so instead of using
pyramidal algorithms we actually use
green algea Brad could use optimization
and somehow first what we did is
actually we show that at least if you
cared about undirected graphs and you
are okay with an approximate solutions
you can actually beat this and 2/3 half
the part in fact you can get a new
linear time algorithm okay except this
dependence of epsilon on the
approximation and then it turns out that
actually once we understood what happens
for it and a little case we also showed
that you can also get an improvement for
the directed and exact case except you
know so far the improvement is only for
small you for small small capacities but
you could have a C being one and there
is still some work to be done to get all
the way to England
okay so this is all like very
interesting work and you know there is I
think a lot of lessons there but somehow
what I want to do
today's I just wanted to you know this
work is viewed as something somewhat
technical often and somehow it at first
you might look at it actually well you
know me and others were developing it we
somehow well I wish we knew call this
optimization then because at that time
it looked somewhat at hawk like things
worked but like somehow each time it was
a surprise that things work and somehow
there was like a big beep you know there
was a big of course you know big
happiness that we made progress that
also a puzzlement like why did it work
so what I want to do in this talk I want
to give you a view of all the
developments but you can just clearly
see it's something natural once you
actually know how great doesn't works so
this is both you know embarrassing but
also like a great way of showing that
you should really try to learn
neighboring areas because you know you
might save yourself quite a lot of time
by doing so actually like not all of
this was radical in the sense but
essentially greatness and we'll just
make it much easier and then there were
some additional insights that you know
you would know like what you need and
how it works okay so let me try to do
with us so essentially let's try to
think about max-flow algorithms that
don't use the traditional augmenting
path framework but actually try to
compute electrical flow as try to
compute maximum flow using a while since
we continue atomization so how we how
would we go about that and for now I
would just focus on the undirected
variant of the problem okay so how would
we go about solving max flow using
gradient descent well we don't have to
be smart I would have told you what is
the algorithm so step number one let's
just cast max flow as a continued
optimization problem so how about the
following way so clearly the language of
code is indifference linear algebra so
let's just try to view if the flow is
linear algebraic object namely a vector
so essentially we just view F as an M
dimensional vector in which like each
coordinate corresponds to one of the
edges and now the sign of this
coordinate tells us the direction and
the value like the absolute value of it
tell us how much flow we flow clearly
now this is just the moment of thinking
you can encode any flow in this way and
essentially you know in this this is the
kind of lossless
of the of the problem so that's great so
now once you know once you know how to
think of the flow in a direct fashion
you just want to phrase it as an
optimization problem so what you do well
here is one way to do it so what you
would like is you would like to optimize
over all the vectors that encode a you
need SD flow okay so what do you would
like to successfully like a flow whose
demands are zero everywhere on SMT x + 2
1 at s and minus 1 at T and then what
you would like to minimize over all the
such flows you would like to minimize
the flow on the maximum or on the like
the maximum flow on an edge okay so
we're talking about the unit capacity
flow here by the way I forgot to mention
that ok so why this is the right
formulation well you just have to think
about this for a moment so essentially
like the nice shortcut notation for this
maximum of the flow will just L infinity
norm of this vector ok and now if you
think about it it seems like the optimal
value of this program will be
essentially 1 over the value of max flow
okay so concession can you can think of
like the optimum solution to the maximum
flow if you just scale it down to just
make it be you know you you need test
you flow you will get exactly the
optimal social here socially this is
really after rescaling this is indeed
solving the maximum flow problem ok so
far so good so now we sort of now we to
phrase our problem as in cadiz
optimization problem so you know so
that's way too one way to to form this
problem but here will be a bit maybe
less intuitive but actually a nicer way
to do it so the other way we can
actually formulate this problem is just
to think about it as minimizing over all
the vectors now it's unconstrained
minimization what we minimize
we minimize the Infinity norm of the
projection of F onto the space of
university flows so if you think about
it you need the space of all the unit
tests if loss is just an affine subspace
of the whole space and you know you can
essentially just define a projection on
the space so essentially now you can you
allow F to be what we like whatever you
want but then before you evaluate it
using a live vision or you just project
it on the closest point in the you know
on the closest point that is a you
Industrie flow okay so this may look a
bit more contrived but instead the same
problem it will be more more convenient
to work with so
you know this is the problem you want to
solve how would we solve it well it does
affect sorry so so let's just think for
a moment what it is that we're trying to
do so certainly we what the way to think
about what we are trying to do is that
there is this affine subspace of unity
flows and now what we are trying to find
we are trying to find a minimum size L
infinity box around the origin that
actually intersects with this affine
subspace okay that's all that we really
want to find so like this kind of
minimum minimum radius in intersection
is exactly the maximum flow we are
looking for so now how should we go
about finding this you know about
finding this intersection you know how
to solve this problem again you don't
have to think there's only one answer
it's great in descent okay so of course
if you now want to apply currents
indirectly were realizing there is some
problem namely the objective is actually
not smooth so I promise you that the
functions we want to minimize are smooth
this one is not so but iam there is
again a simple and principled solution
for this you all you just do the stuff
on it
so there are general techniques that
essentially can take such a in a non
smooth function so here is a non smooth
point of this function and produce a
function other function that is smooth
and approximates your original function
as closely as possible so in the case of
you know of alpha 2 norm the right
function to use is just like softmax
it looks nasty but is actually very
simple and this we all you just do it
just now instead of working with the
original function you just work with
minimization of the smooth running of
this country okay so now your objective
is smooth and so you know everything is
fine except now the other problem is now
how do you actually compute this
projection okay so I make you minimize a
function and the problem is that to
evaluate this function even you have to
compute its protection
how do you do this well it turns out
that again we are lucky or maybe there
is something more than life here
essentially turns out not computing
factor production so computing the
closest flow to a the closest human
testing flow to a given flow is actually
a well-known primitive in different
contexts namely this corresponds to
computing illogical flaws or
equivalently solving collaboration
systems and for that we actually have
this beautiful work of Sweetman and tang
and then all this beautiful
simplification afterwards that
less that you can compute such a
projection in nearly linear time okay so
we lucked out and actually now
evaluating this function also compute
its gradient
actually is you know we can do it very
efficiently so that's great so now we
can run the grain descent we have an
algorithm it works the question is now
how fast does it work so recall that you
know the key thing that we needed to
bound here is the number of iterations
of our algo and this was the general
bound that we got so what is beta well
you have to compute it for a moment it's
as hard but like once you do it you
realize that the beta here is 1 over
epsilon and this 1 over epsilon comes
due to smoothing so actually whatever we
lose due to the fact that we are
smoothening it and so this is you know
the beta is 1 over epsilon how about the
R squared so what is the distance of the
inter point let's say the or 0 solution
to the you know to the optimal solution
well clearly it is always at most M yes
because in the worst case f star is an
optimal solution it never flows more
than one on any of the edges so clearly
this l2 norm squared would be always at
most putting all of this together we
suddenly get you know each detail takes
o of M time so clearly we have just now
M squared over epsilon squared algorithm
so the good news is we just got another
word without much thinking and that's
always appreciated of course the problem
is that this running time is not great
now we definitely know how to solve a
max flow faster but first of all you
know what I want to emphasize here is
that our approach is principled and
robust second of all this was just a
generic of the shell all of the chef's
algorithm ok once we know what we want
to do then in terms of this framework
gives us a lot of power to actually
adjust it appropriately so essentially
the stuff one of the King one of the
sort of things we can now take advantage
of isn't actually that great design is
just much broader tool than what I just
told you so far so instead of so so far
you know if you look about what we
happen so essentially all that was
happening that there's was it's like
sandwiching inequality okay for this for
this you know for this a tail or tail
and you know essentially the values of
alpha and beta told us which of the
running time bounds we had okay now the
thing here is that like
we do know this properly before but so
far I was just using you know the
Euclidean norm over here okay
and that was all natural this is the
most natural nor not we know but
actually there is nothing special about
using l2 norm here you can use any norm
you you know you you wish and everything
will work so the only thing that will
change is essentially will change that
the direction in the gradient that you
will need to take would be a bit
different it will correspond to just
solving of this you know of this simple
problem so for the case of l2 this this
solution is just exactly the vector
itself so that's why we are moving the
direction of minus gradient for other
norms you actually get a bit different
directions but that's again very
automatic and it's easy to easy to get
so now you know once you know that you
can choose whatever norm you want well
now we can actually think of choosing a
norm that makes these parameters alpha
and beta as close to each other as
possible okay so let's do that for max
flow so it turns out if you think about
it for a moment it will be clean for a
moment why so the right norm to analyze
you know a degree in descent for max
flow is actually not the l2 norm but
actually the LM fitting okay so what
happens if you analyze the same
algorithm but from the point of your
value fit inner well now our radius our
distance from a from you know from
optimum actually goes goes down from
being m2 at most 1 why well because
again the largest correlated we ever
will have is 1 and that is exactly the
Allen fit in all of the of the of the of
the flow so this is great so we went
from M to 1
now how about better well better becomes
a bit you know more difficult now
because actually it is no longer 1 over
Epsilon we are losing square root of M
and this just corresponds to the
difference between the l2 norm and then
video so that's what you lose okay but
this is not M this is just square root
of M and as a result the runtime you are
getting now is M to the three-halves
over epsilon squared so again we did we
didn't do much and suddenly we are
matching already the running time of the
best computer algorithms and again we
are just constant what can we do next
well so one thing that I did actually
so this is the this is the paper that
the dick mentioned truly we find a way
and you can you can think of it as a way
of essentially improving this bount a
bit essentially like as I told you the
square root of M comes from the
difference between l 2-norm
and alpha d norm and what you can show
is that there is some way of doing the
perturbations that actually will enable
you to effectively get in n to the one
third dependence as opposed to M to the
one half so you are already beating the
M to the tree have one time and
essentially there was also a paper by
Lee ro and silver stava that got similar
bound by different also grain dozen
technique okay so but it is that all
that we can get here when you use
different geometry well the answer is no
and this was the inside of you know of
of Jonah Sherman and drum calendar drum
color intact lee lorenzo recchia and
seat fault
so this is okay yes you can use a
different geometry to analyze it but
also you can change the objective to
instead of using the protection in the
l2 norm you might actually use an object
if you leave it in you
okay so what happens if you do that so
essentially you just like the difference
is the same except now to close this
measure in L infinity norm as opposed to
L if L tomorrow what does change well we
still have that the distance to optimum
is at most one that's great but actually
what is nice is that now beta becomes
again one over epsilon so this is great
so the number of iterations is just like
1 over epsilon squared so this is
essentially you know really the best we
can hope here in a moment anyway
so you know are we done well there is a
problem so the problem is that now once
I change the projection it actually
becomes a different problem to compute a
different algorithm problem to compute
it in particular the production of an
all zero vector is exactly the max-flow
that we are looking for so clearly this
is not great because you know we
essentially have to solve the problem to
solve the problem fast and that's not
the right way to do it however it you
know to you might think okay is this
approach doomed to failure well it turns
out that no so essentially this is like
a beauty of this kind of approaches that
what you can do you don't really need to
use exact projection
just having an approximate projection is
totally fine and what is even better is
that the projection like the
approximation factor you have will not
be a part of the quality of the solution
but actually it will just influence your
running time so you might take longer to
converge but you this part of the
solution will be still the same so in
particularly in in some of my works
there was an instant construction of a
you know m2 little o of one approximate
projection for max flow and essentially
then you can put it together and get
this needle in your running time which
then was improved and actually recently
Sherman even saved on one of this power
of one over epsilon B was actually
interesting from coaches of me from the
point of view as well
and essentially we got you know the best
one can get here okay and everything
happened in the gradient descent frame
okay right so this was the undirected
case so let's just talk about the
directed case so how this was about
approximate and undirected case what
does happen in the directed mass flow
setting well you know the obvious hope
here would be that we can just translate
the progress on the approximate and the
red max flow to the directed setting
right away
specifically you know one thing that
should make us sort of happy here is
that you can prove that being able to
show to solve exact undirected max flow
problem is equivalent to directed max
flow program so working with ethyl
graphs is totally fine the only problem
is that actually we really need this
exact here and the approximation that we
are getting from this metal so far is
just not sufficient to make this
reduction go through okay
in a sense dislikes muffin ink and the
approximate projection just looks too
much information about the function to
get exact solution okay so what is the
idea well again you don't have to be
smart we just look at to your continues
up to mediation book and what you do is
just you realize that there is a way so
what you should do just choose the
change the objective in a way that it
makes it nicer and only locally instead
of like sort of nicer only locally
instead of globally so smoothening
you are trying to make the function
globally nice what you should do instead
you just try to make it only locally
nice and sometimes you know and sort of
not al-abadi know at the at the gain of
not losing too much in terms of
approximation so there is a method that
actually achieves that
and this method is essentially
corresponds to solving linear programs
using interior point methods so let's
talk briefly about that so sort of the
setup here is just following so imagine
you have an linear program and somehow
the difficult constraints here are this
feasibility constraints this is what
makes this program hard and somehow the
idea underlying the whole question is
essentially well you want to really turn
this you know constrained minimization
question into an unconstrained mediation
question that's nice so the way you do
what you essentially introduce a barrier
function that kind of well like there is
like logarithm of the slack of each of
the constraints that essentially
explodes whenever you are getting close
to violating this constraint so what
happens now now is that this barrier
term
like you know and forces implicitly the
feasibility and you know clearly of
course we are now solving a different
problem than we wanted to solve but as
long as this kind of proportionality
parameters stays positive but becomes
small essentially in the limit we are
getting the solution we are looking for
okay so you know and you can assume that
you can even solve this problem for a
large value of MU which is not that
interesting but actually will be useful
we know just easily okay so this is a
set up and now of course natural ideas
now now we have an unconstrained
minimization problem we just need to
minimize this F mu F mu X to get the
optimal solution for for sufficiently
small mu Daniel there is natural way to
solve it let's use green descent and
this actually will work as an algorithm
except the condition number might be
very bad and essentially we will not the
others will not be fast enough so
essentially what you do is this is
essentially the last trick in the whole
bag of gradient descent methods then
when you try to as I said you try to
manipulate the geometry of the problem
to ensure that the condition number is
always good okay so how does it like how
does it work well essentially this is
the most advanced or essentially that
the last idea in the indian descent
method framework may be the something
called Newton's method so what's
happening here so recall you know this
was our Taylor approximation of the
function our like linear approximation
and then our tale
so if you think about that is that we in
the end what you want we want to find
some norm in which we can just sort of
sandwich this tail from as a lower and
upper quadratic in the store okay but
you know if you think about how does
this tail look like then you will
realize that the sense right there is
like one best way to choose the norm
so the solution inequality becomes very
tight almost slam totally so what you
essentially do you set up this norm to
be something called local norm in which
this norm of the vector is given by the
Hessian of the function so this is
exactly the term that you have over here
so this is not hard to see that as long
as Delta is small enough then this
sandwich think you know this error term
is exactly dominated by exactly this
quadratic term which is exactly the
quadratic in the local norm and you have
a condition number close to one so you
eat you automatically have rapid
convergence so this is great you just
chose the geometry that makes your makes
visan's converge very very fast except
there are kids so the first caveat is
that essentially the question is like
how small is small enough okay so is
actually our distance to optimum small
enough for this approximation to hold
usually not and the other question is
actually when you compute what is the
direction I should move now that
corresponds to the steepest direction
respect to this norm then actually it
corresponds to computing the inverse of
the Hessian times the gradient and
essentially this in general might be
quite slow okay so there are two caveats
of like so Newton method is really nice
because it always chooses the best
geometry for your problem except you
know it's not clear it's only a local
analysis not a global conversion Alice's
and also you know actually taking a step
in this norm can be quite expensive but
it turns out that here we can actually
make it work so what you do is
essentially you parameterize your
problem using this mu and what you have
is you you just sort of always ensure
that you only use Newton's method with
whenever this rapid converges analysis
actually does hold so you start with
some optimum solution for some you know
the LP mu for some large value of mu and
now you just gradually improve it so
what you do is you have your current
optimal solution
X mu star for some value of mu and then
you use Newton's method to find an
optimum solution X mu prime star for
some smaller mu prime that is chosen to
be well smaller but that's sufficiently
large so actually you know the new the
new optimum solution is close to your
initial solution and this rapid
convergence of Newton's method actually
works okay so this is the sort of the
theory but here is the picture to have
so if this is the feasible region of
your LP that you are trying to minimize
over so what you are really and this is
the cost and this is the optimum
solution so what you are doing is that
essentially well if you look at this
solution X mu star for all these values
of MU from 0 all the way to infinity
then till corresponds to somehow a path
in the feasible space that starts at
something called like analytic center of
this feasible region and then as mu gets
smaller and smaller and smaller it
converges towards the optimum and now
all that we really are doing by this
kind of you know this successive uses of
Newton's method we are just trying to
follow this curve in a discreet fashion
and essentially the length of this step
is just dictated by the you know how far
can we go
so this rapid converter Cerritos method
is still valid ok so this is the idea
and this is how these things work so
this is how it solving your problems
with you three-point methods now the
question is can it give us a max faster
max flow algorithm and you know the
conventional wisdom if you ask people
like some time ago would say no way this
will be too slow it will work of course
but it will be so slow and somehow the
problem is exactly what I told you is
that in each step you have to sort of
compute you know the like the the
product of the gradient times the
inverse of the Hessian which corresponds
to solving a linear system in the
Hessian and this is you know this is
usually very very expensive however that
can spin one notice that in ten will
never use solved maximum flow problem
then the Hessian of your function is
actually laplacian matrix and you can
use this fast represent solvers to
implement the step need to be very fast
so suddenly this problem is no longer a
problem so now the only question that
remains is ok so we know that each step
is fast the question is now how many
steps do we need to actually converge
and this was you know one of the central
questions in and still is one of those
question in mathematical programming in
Part B in particular Jim Dunnigan showed
that and this is still the current
essentially were almost the well the
best current bound it says a number of
iterations you need is roughly square
root of M times log 1 over Epsilon so
when you put it together this gives you
an M to the three-halves algorithm which
exactly coincides with you know the best
known computer algorithms that was very
disappointed to discover but and you
might think that this is the dead end
and but turns out to be not the case so
what turns out is that some time ago I
showed that there is kind of
perturbation techniques that allows you
to speed up the convergence of interior
parameters there is though a big caveat
that in order to get the speed up I
actually have to perturb also the cost
function so I will solve and I will
solve you know arbitrary linear program
faster except the program I will solve
will not be the program you gave me so
this is a method of limited useful
usefulness still for max flow it
actually gives us improvement and also a
more sophisticated variant of it due to
Lee and seat fourth actually show that
you can gain something here permanently
for all the linear programs namely you
can change this m to be just n so
specially instead of number of
inequalities you can essentially get
just the dimension of the problem which
is always small okay great so this is
essentially almost all of the technical
stuff I have to say today so one point
that I want to make here is that
essentially this you know if you look at
the way I talked about this maximum flow
algorithm there was this kind of
narrative of there are this classical
algorithm in there has this model
algorithm so the classical one are like
things like augmenting paths they are
purely combinatorial greedy and simple
and then there is this you know and some
could say natural and then there is this
weird entry or metal stuff that sort of
is clearly that continuous linear
algebra is greedy but in a sophisticated
manner and not simple and not natural at
least to many people including some of
my colleagues that I co-taught a class
with ok so you might say okay so this is
like very divisive view of things and
you know is it actually the right way to
think about it and you know what I
actually showed is that not really so
even though the album that I told you
about uses the Ricoh method what you can
do actually you can find an algorithm
that
purely in the argumentum path framework
so you can get an argument in per frame
or based algorithm that gives you a
similar I am in fact a bits a bit better
it just uses some strange things that
actually come as an inspiration from
integral metals but this is a completely
legit argument in path algorithm so
augmenting paths are good are still you
know it's still the best one and somehow
what is even more interesting is
actually when you look at what this
algorithm is doing and you look at the
previous augmenting path previous best
algorithm path algorithms and you
realize that our algorithm can be viewed
as a more sophisticated version of
whatever was done before so clearly in a
sense you know this kind of you know in
this kind of disjointness of classic and
modern metals here is actually very
illusionary indeed we are talking about
very similar concepts and I found it
quite quite fascinating so you can
actually look back and see it in Manik
and in many classic computer networks
from X flow and view them through the
lens of course optimization as well okay
so this is all that I wanted to talk
about max flow so since I have only five
minutes so let me just very quickly talk
about some other other instances and
this is only because I want to show you
this is really not about max flow this
is a much broader phenomena so one set
of problems that I wanted to mention is
as exactly matric scaling and and matrix
balancing so in matok maybe I would just
skip through it but like the point is
that there are just some very simple
primitives like so this has some kind of
pre-processing step in algebra that
actually turned out to be very important
and useful in certainly algebraic
concepts so in particular they have been
heavily studied in scientific computing
for the last 50 years or so okay and you
know they are implemented in you know in
many libraries because this is really
how you process or things when you want
to do I gain value computation or you
want to solve linear system and you know
they also have application in TCS like
detecting perfect matchings and
approximating permanent so these are
clearly you know a clearly problems you
might care about and there is even some
nice connection to logical flow you can
do them as a generalization of
analytical flow so it's a problem
interesting and the question now is you
know how would you solve them so as I
said there was like 50 years of work on
this problem but what it turns out
is actually the right approach by now
right approach to us it's essentially
again use continue optimization so you
can view both of these problems as you
know just approach solving them by just
viewing you know like this by just
solving certain unconstrained
immunization problems so to set up a
problem and you just apply credence into
it what you will what will happen is
that this will recover classic
algorithms for this problems that were
known before and this will give you good
dependence on one parameter but will not
allow you to compute like optimal
solutions and it turns out that once you
use it on the next step one so we know
that you can get fast algorithms that
are approximate then you do Newton's
method and you again get you know you
again get algorithms that actually exact
so essentially what you what happens is
once again the Hessian of this function
you have to minimize is a general person
matrix so each step you can implement it
quickly and then the only thing that you
are missing is essentially you need to
find a way in which you use this kind of
Newton step to make more progress so
essentially just I will just show you
the picture because that's all that I
really wanted to show you here is that
so what you do now is that whenever you
have your current point so this is the
optimum point and this is the current
point what you do is just you just
consider the neighborhood of this point
in which this Hessian essentially
remains unchanged okay so this
corresponds to the quadratic
approximation of the function so
essentially the first two terms of the
Taylor expansion to roughly remain
unchanged like in all of this
neighborhood of this point and then what
you do you just find the minimizer of
this function in this neighborhood and
go in the direction this of course may
not directly bring you closer to the
optimum solution because what you
probably would like to do we just would
like to move in this direction but you
can show that this brings you more
enough and essentially you can show that
you know after not too many iterations
you actually get you know get to a
solution so there are two independent
works that actually use very similar
insights and in the end so this is this
is work with Michael Cohen and Dmitry
tsipras my student Adrienne Prado also
my student and since you can get a near
linear running time and I will not
explain what even linear humans but like
the sort of the point here is that in
the end everything is going descent this
is the way once you suddenly get like a
very
and obvious algorithms and in some sense
close to optimum running okay so that's
the last slide that I have on anything
technical is the lathe another domain
name in case every problem which if you
know anything about online algorithms
this is you know one of the most
prominent problems in that field and it
was like heavily studied but not very
yet not well understood by any chance
and I think everyone agrees with me that
so there were some work so far but you
know somehow the golden standard if you
want to get to we want to have like four
randomized algorithm on to get like poly
log competitiveness and we achieved
something like that before but somehow
the thing that I really didn't like even
though I was a kraut or I didn't like
about it it was a somewhat ad hoc and it
was very hard to generalize like it
worked but you didn't really know why
well you could see the proof but that
wasn't the first factory explanation so
what we did is what we did recently with
Sebastian boo back Michael Cohen James
Lee and in fact Lee is actually we
figured out the I think what I believe
to be the right way of thinking about
this problem and again the view turns
out to be the gradient or mirror of the
sent view of this problem so what we get
is that now once we talk about mirror
descent
well our can descent the general
algorithm is obvious it's mirror descent
the only progress specific part is
choice of the of a mirror map which
corresponds to something like choosing
the right norm to know the right
geometry it turns out that you know if
you use something called multi scale
lattice entropy it will give you an
improve running time bound and in fact
you know concurrently james lee also
showed that there is even a different
mirror map that gives you a purely poly
log k dependence so again it's not about
the result here it just about the view
that essentially this was again a view
that enabled us to to see you know
online Algirdas like one of the most
protocol only algorithms from the point
of view of proteins optimization and
again i don't have time to say more i
think this is a view that can actually
apply to much broader class of online
problems as well okay so let me just
conclude and talk about the bigger
picture here so I hope I made some kind
of case that continues optimization /
gradient descent gives us a new and
powerful perspective on algorithms at
least some of the algorithms
I claim this applies more broadly and
somehow the important feature that I
really like is that it is principled in
the robust you know you have a general
of this method and then you just have to
have a little bit of an art to just
fine-tune it and improve it but somehow
the the point of stuff is always clear
and psychologically I think it is very
important interestingly it turns out
that once you cast things in this
framework a lot of previous solutions
turn out to be actually installation of
it even though you know no one thought
about it at the time but in that usually
the natural way to do things who claim
the same turns out to be what someone
thought hard about to actually get this
is actually quite amazing and somehow
this point and somehow the key thing to
actually to Duke tourism or to continue
musician people that somehow the very
important part that actually makes it
work is that we actually have this very
fast data structure in very fast
algorithms for solving some of these
primitives in algebraic primitives that
underlie all of it like Larson solvers
also figure does so that is really like
both sides really have to contribute to
make it work so now the question to you
is you know how does this change the
landscape of others so in particular you
know one homework I would like to have
for all of you and I'm really minute is
whatever you do think hard if you know
maybe might seem crazy at the beginning
but think hard could I view it as a
gradient descent kind of outward like
again at first it may seem crazy but
then you know now there is many example
like specification can be used as a good
innocent you know okay so other things
that are in works also can be for
instance so it's actually quite
surprising how many things you can cast
in this framework even though at first
you would think that this is completely
this thing should not be applicable okay
and it's not only about solving TCS
problem is actually this you know this
this work touches on like very core
questions photos musician too so in
particular you know interdepartmental
iteration bounds and so on and so on and
we already had a lot of progress in this
in this context exactly when we studied
concrete TCS problems from this domain
so and you know my major gripe here is
actually why the heck we don't teach
gradient descent or student in algorithm
so you know I try to tell you at MIT you
know I
each other good algorithms and then I
insist on you know on having done great
in the center there as well but somehow
you know clearly none of the three major
books on algorithms has anything about
computer optimization or getting the
cent and I really think this has to
change not only because of the planning
so so that I think this is really
important because we are like robbing
the students of you know very important
part of algorithmic knowledge you know I
wish someone told me about this when I
was an undergrad no one did
okay so finally just this is the shout
out to the people in the program so
somehow yes we spend the semester very
enjoyable seven so together and you
might say our job here was breathing
stuff and we definitely started but we
hardly ended okay so I think that only
now you know I hope we will go back to
our event is you know we will relax
while teaching and doing all this on all
this great stuff that will be the time
when we really have you know like have
have the moment to think about how to
sort of get the insight that we acquire
during this interaction in like at Simon
stitute to actually you know have some
new and great results so I hope that's
what will happen thank you
[Applause]